in previous videos you saw us renovating
our sketchy room now we are gonna build
the roof on it we are trying to keep as
much as we come from the old building in
order to reuse the materials
we kept the foundations part of the
walls bricks and rooftops but also we
needed to reinforce the whole structure
let's see how it works with the weight
of the new roof welcome to another
project Camp update
rainy weather will be coming soon so we
need to get the roof done quite fast
this has the challenge of getting all
the materials on time as we are going to
make different layers with them
but first I want to show you a problem
we have at the bottom of the ruin
we always assume that the granite visor
were best foundation but we're a good
friend but recently we discovered that
it's not in that good state
so as you can see this Granite is a bit
brittle and
up we also discovered some cracks on it
as you can see here
Charleston sounds
a bit Hollow
the big being of the roof is going to
lay here which is going to bring the
weight to this rock so we're gonna
reinforce this area in order to have our
roof on top of a solid base to yeah be a
bit safe let's do it
we're cutting into the granite a little
bit
so we can have them nice and tight with
the wall
so
it's kind of a sketchy process but
I'm cutting into the Rock
and then doing a second cut
and slowly taking out sections it's very
dusty
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hey we are back in the workspace we have
already our metal and now it's time to
metal work
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
for the bottom is ready I tried to move
it myself down but I end up with a bit
of back pain so now I found some friends
to move it with me
now
[Music]
oh yeah
we're good okay
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
limestone
foreign
so we have this frame in place now these
beams are well supported
and we're gonna start to work safely in
the roof
do it
so now that we've reinforced the bottom
part of the ruin we can start working on
the roof
it's going to be a tiled roof and it's
going to consist of six layers let me
show you in the 3D model
so before you could say Dave put in this
big beam frame into the house on this
Frame we are going to have
the rafters
and the cork insulation is going to lay
on top of the rafters it's six
centimeters thick
uh a foil membrane will go over the cork
layer
on top of the membrane we have the
counter buttons
on the counter buttons set the buttons
and on top of the buttons we can put the
roof tiles
before we start working on the roof I
would like to introduce you to our new
friend Frank
he's going to help me because it's a
pretty big job you've already seen him
previously but he's going to introduce
himself properly now
hi my name is Frank I'm 33 years old and
I'm from Germany some years ago I quit
my job in industry and decided to go
traveling with my brother on our travels
to India I learned about yoga and
natural building which are now two of my
passions and also coffee foreign so I
became a yoga teacher and recently I
finished my training as a carpenter now
I came to project Camp to put my skills
to work I learned that it's important to
do things that are meaningful to us
rather than chasing after money or
careers by doing the things that we
enjoy and give meaning to us we can
become much happier and help to make the
world a little better
but for the moment the ruin needs a roof
so let's see what I can bring to it
okay now we're ready to start working on
the roof and the first step will be
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
we just got this pile of wood freshly
delivered
and we're gonna use it to finish the
roof so normally we get all our wood
from The Sawmill here in the village
but most of the times it's it's bendy
and it's not dry but now we found a guy
close by you can deliver this already
dried nice and straight wood
foreign
[Music]
foreign
got the last Raptor here
oh I was traveling
time to put the first rafter on we've
put this uh little block here the angle
of the roof filling the gap on the roof
Rich beam
[Music]
okay
looks alright to me
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
look at this
nice beams
yeah sorry enough
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
filmmaking nothing too complicated
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
on this corner
and for that yeah I got myself
attached to the Rope got a plank in
place and now we screw it down
[Music]
do you have good insurance
no
[Applause]
we've got this little challenge of a
square roof on another Square house
and it means that our Rafters are not
running over the walls
as you can see here
we are putting extra beams on top of the
wall
and later we're close it here
with cement to have somewhat of a
airtight connection
look at this brick
it's exactly I'm constantly Amazed by my
own uh
skills
[Music]
this is like the car is arriving but
there's a bit of a situation here seems
that the truck is stuck so we're gonna
check and help the guy
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ready to isolate our workplace
we choose this material because it is
natural it's also grown close by it's
local it's barely processed so they just
get the leftover cork they heat it up
they compress it and they have this
thick planks that we are gonna use to
insulate our building we will put it in
the walls and in the roof we're gonna
use it for his awesome properties as an
insulation material if you want to get
more in depth you can check the outdo 53
you can see how is it made where is it
coming from we want to give it this try
and see how it reacts how it isolates in
the summer how it reacts in Winter yeah
we like it let's cork let's cork
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
first half of the roof is in place we
made it so that it sticks over on the
top of the ridge we are now going to cut
over the ridge to have a nice straight
edge
speed it should be set on the maximum
depth it is I mean speed speed
yes oh there's a speed dial I didn't
know but it's a six
foreign
is coming
we have to we have to close the roof
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this will make sure that the wind and
the water
cannot go into the cork
and it also finishes off the beam
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
man installation are now in place and as
you can see between the Cork and the
buttons we have included a waterproof
layer we are not really sure about this
layer as we are introducing new plastic
in our building
finally we went for it in order to
prevent water and moisture it will keep
our materials in good condition in the
long run so the overall impact could be
reduced we are still not sure if it's
worth adding Advanced material like this
or if it is better to keep it more
natural Let's see we would like to learn
more about it so let us know if you have
any thoughts
this is what we have done this week roof
is now almost there and next move will
be finishing it by adding buttons and
rooftops we hope to have it ready for
next week if there is no serious
unexpected events in between
thanks for watching and see you in the
next update
wait wait wait if you like what we do
support us in patreon to watch the
videos one week ahead